I would love to do it someone licensed
my face so they could stick a penis in
it pound my face to death dude and then
[ __ ] like I don't know pay me like
five G's a month or something yeah that
seems like a fair deal
[Music]
uh very recently it was reported that
Bruce Willis in the first deal of its
kind had sold his face to a deep fake
company called Deep cake
and then his agent just said that those
were false rumors and news even though
it was widely spread on a bunch of
different news sources that got picked
up I thought that was gonna be a good
idea because I heard he can't talk no
more or some [ __ ] exactly so that's also
why a lot of people hella believed it so
is everybody caught up with Bruce
Willis's unfortunateness yeah he's
Aphasia right what yes that's right yeah
what's Aphasia it's it's Aphasia what
did you say am I from Tennessee I don't
know no it's it's called Aphasia it's
like it [ __ ] with his head so he can't
he he's not he has difficulty
remembering certain things yeah and
speaking a little bit right yeah saying
things um poor guy yeah so um it was
rumored that he had sold the likeness
and the rights to his face so that he
could literally continue his acting
career and have Bruce Willis continue
because
um it's been a thing recently even for
like Val Kilmer we talked about it you
know what I mean like Ai and voice act
uh voice Ai and stuff like that
recreating Carrie Fisher exactly oh yeah
Luke Skywalker is did that yeah Tupac no
I'm just kidding but basically just the
idea of using new AI technology and deep
fake and stuff like that the idealism
That's like [ __ ] Skynet idealism but
the idealism if you don't immediately go
straight to like porno or something like
that
um you're you're thinking about being
able to bring somebody's likeness and
their voice back so they can do any type
of advertisement any type of media movie
TV whatever the [ __ ]
um so it was supposed to be a first deal
of its kind but it was fake news uh and
his agent recently came out and said
that wasn't true because that's stupid
and ridiculous
is it is it stupid yeah I don't know I
think that's a pretty good lie
I think so too I guess would you do it
you know I mean and what would the price
be and then think about like how far is
that this is like for eternity type [ __ ]
right you sell like the likeness of your
face I guess the benefit to that would
be your estate after you die can still
make money like your family your necks
of Kingston Bruce Willis I would love to
do it someone licensed my face so they
could stick a penis in it pound my face
to death dude and then [ __ ] like I
don't know pay me like five G's a month
or something yeah that seems like a fair
deal like jeez a month that's not that
five G's a month I think I would I would
look at that you could live off that you
pound your Dead face well my face I'll
be aging but my face is still the young
youthful face that's 20s bars and it's
just constant [ __ ] pounding my fate
like [ __ ] getting skull [ __ ] but you
get five G's a month that's pretty good
that's pretty good and then maybe like
one or two percent you're underselling
yourself I think we would get like six
would you want to be school [ __ ] by
your mom or your dad my dad has the
penis oh God all right well you know
what's crazy though is that if oh well
let's say this was true it's a great
answer and that uh Bruce Willis is like
Bruce Willis did sign off right would
that be precedent for like in the future
that people started signing off the
rights to past people like if you own
the estate of like Marilyn Monroe you
could now sign Michael Jackson dude I
would do Michael Jackson for sure I'd
watch that you'd watch Moonwalker too
dude two and three sign me up watch
Neverland too yeah I want to see more
stories of uh some other kids that have
hung out with Michael Jackson because
that's what Neverland one was about was
it Neverland it's not never led by the
way Neverland was it well that's what
they're trying to do yeah Sarah Marshall
yeah I thought that I thought that's the
name of the document I watched the
documentary and I was very like I
watched it too and I believed every word
of it and there's not a liar next to me
to say otherwise
he did it bro yep there's all these
really funny uh speaking of Michael
Jackson there's all these really funny
clips of him like just being a [ __ ] a
weirdo in his day-to-day life that's
just being circulated on like Instagram
like memes or it's just like they're in
a limousine I attacked Joe in this and
he just and this is like uh like knows
Michael Jackson like with his oh good
yeah knows Michael yeah yeah keep in
mind he's a genius okay and he's a
genius Bro Look Geniuses don't operate
in regular World 100 and you could tell
and he kind of reminds me of Joan a
little bit he's in a limo and there's a
bunch of fans swarming
um like the car and he's with his agent
and he's like oh look at her titties
right there and that's all he says and
that's all he doesn't like kids then
well no he just pointed out he likes
titties he can like both it's
observational comedy there he goes he
goes ah look at those titties right
there and I just thought I never thought
I would ever hear Michael Jackson point
at a later I don't think you could like
both can you dude I'm not an expert on
this I'm just saying I'm just clip on
here but just imagine him just pointing
out some titties like that's funny it's
Michael Jackson maybe maybe he was
saying look at them kitties over there
maybe probably honestly you know knowing
Michael the way I do from Clips yeah
you're right I could I could have
misheard it I could have misheard it and
out of context Clips right that makes
sense to me God like give him hot milk
that's my favorite clip of him he's like
oh no what I do with children's very
Charming he's like I have to give him
hot milk and it's like Jesus come on to
get him sleepy huh you need just one
honest friend to sit next to you go
Michael
cold milk don't say that oh they like it
cold I don't know Mike the Fred's not
that good yeah he's not different he's
he's you know he's got something iced
milk do you remember when uh Bruce Lee's
Game of Death how uh he died so they
couldn't finish it yeah and then they
just put like a still shot of his
[ __ ] head on a guy's body it looks so
bad that was the original defect and
then for the and then for his funeral in
the movie they used his actual [ __ ]
funeral and they no way they use this
real dead body going through the street
talk about playing a cheap huh is that
crazy Jesus Christ budget dude if they
if they sold his likeness would you
support watching new Bruce Lee films
that's hard though because like selling
the likeness to his face doesn't mean
the person can replicate his body well
yeah there's a lot of great stuff I saw
other parts all right let's say you have
let's say you have rush hour five or
whatever and it's dead Bruce Lee and
dead who's the black dude gotta be dead
it has to be a comedy relief Lee so it's
gonna be a funny Richard Pryor Richard
Pryor Richard Pryor Bruce Lee oh [ __ ]
that would have been a great movie and
they were around at the same time yeah
that'd be pretty good that would be
tight that's iconic yeah that's real
that's actually really I got excited
somebody buy the rice to their faces and
let's make it I'd watch that I think we
can get the rights to Bruce Lee's face
yeah it's tough though because ever
since I think we can it's tough for me
personally because ever since I saw once
upon a time in Hollywood I just see
Bruce Lee is a huge blubbering [ __ ] now
you got slammed dude they were pissed
about I mean they're still pissed about
that yeah that's for sure metal now well
that's because Quentin Tarantino's basis
for that wasn't based on real truth
nothing was in that whole movie and it
was to prove a point no the last part
because Brad Pitt had to be a badass
right so he had to beat up the big the
Bruce Lee part was like come on I still
didn't like that movie I didn't either
it was an awful movie yeah no they're
made they're made to expose people who
don't understand Cinema so yeah
[Laughter]
you say you don't like a Quentin movie
someone's gonna go well of course you
don't like it yeah you're not emotional
damage yeah you don't go to groundwork
coffee of course you don't know of
course you don't you gotta go to Nick's
Cafe there's some movies that it's like
it's meant for you to like like when I
saw the master and I didn't like it I
got [ __ ] on which one's the mess it's
uh who is it Paul Thomas Anderson and uh
and what's his name Joaquin Phoenix oh
yeah that's right and I thought what's
his name's in it too oh the oh the older
Phillips yeah I'm thinking about the
Grand Master no I wish it was that
people but yeah I didn't like it and
then all the [ __ ] Cinema people went
with were like oh my God bless your
heart yeah I'm sorry you're so stupid no
it [ __ ] sucked a little dancer boy
sorry it wasn't like You Got Served
yeah he's like oh honey watch watch
honey
sorry there wasn't
it oh no but I guess it's like some kind
of thing about it's supposed to be
reflecting Scientology or something but
like that's also kind of boring so yeah
it was a boring movie dude Scientology
is pretty not boring what are your
guys's top
like one or two of your top five
favorite films just around them one or
two of your top five yeah so like you
know sometimes decimal's more question
ever they give me top five name the top
two
no cause sometimes you can't you're like
I don't know how to play some but I know
it's in my top ten two and number four
you know what I'm talking about yeah
yeah sometimes you're like I know it's
my top 10 but I don't know where it is
in my top ten yeah yeah like that that's
so funny Big Lebowski I Gotta Go Big
Lebowski everyone loves it now but I
[ __ ] love that movie ever since my
dad brought it home from a video store
oh cool yeah it was we were you saw that
at an early age I saw an early age I was
yeah and my dad brought it home and he
only let me watch it with them so they
kind of felt cool right because I have
little brothers and like it's like you
can't watch it actually yeah
there's bad words you can't watch you're
not laugh I'm gonna make sure I love
this movie yeah yeah but we were dying
laughing like that movie killed me so I
always have that memory we still
watching with their dad that movie no I
don't talk to him okay
do you guys make it like a thing like
every year during Christmas or something
we were watching we watched Bad Santa
every year at Christmas oh wow that
movie
I've never seen that what about you the
first one the first one's way oh second
one the second one garbage yeah what's
your top two out of five top two out of
five
um I don't know I could think of one
that I uh always go back to The Truman
Show oh yes oh it's so freaking good the
concept was just great and you know Jim
Carrey really Nails it so good afternoon
good evening and good night what's your
what's your favorite top two out of five
out of two she only said one do you want
to say two was that number five you
don't have to say two top five out of
two oh
that means you have to include the
sequels yeah first one that comes to
mind is the best of the best oh wow
right number four no number one number
four is the best one literally in the
order number one two and then three and
then I don't even know about four number
one's fire number one's [ __ ] the bomb
wow I love I love Phillip Reed though
yeah I don't know maybe it was just that
time that that I just grew up and I just
you know I rented that video from
Hollywood videos like a two-day rental
so I'd watch as many times as possible
before I returned it yeah I watched it
11 times in a row you know what I mean I
[ __ ] fell in love with it and that's
good this is how it is you know more
than blood sport oh
I loved Bloodsport too but best of the
best just had a hold on me at that
particular age I think when I was also
like uh in Taekwondo as well yeah yeah
yeah you know oh yeah yeah yeah that's
true and it helps out like blood sweat's
a little sad because all the Asians
didn't get [ __ ] up yeah except for
that [ __ ] french guy thing that's why
I love Karate Kid dude oh I'm pretty
good oh maybe you should get destroyed
white kid learns remember that kid who's
the kid in the third one or whatever the
kid who's like mad all the time is
[ __ ] matter he's the second one the
second one second he's [ __ ] so pissed
and everything he's just like
every [ __ ] seat I'm like my god dude
he's just like a [ __ ] hot head guy
yeah
[Laughter]
he's pumping gas and he's just he's just
like pumping gas he's like
it's like all right dude Jesus Christ I
think I met that guy in Hawaii I think I
went to his like he has a Hawaiian
restaurant was he mad yeah he's pissed
get the katsu you [ __ ] idiot
[Music]